au départ je voulais à plus de
l'exposition tout est là quand il est
vrai que là la nature la nature est vive
entre el pais dit chantal cris parfois
aussi et puis je me suis rendu compte
que tout cela c'était tout cela nous
était offert et qui est que soient
incités simplement qu'on prenne le temps
de bien entrer dedans bien se perdre
dedans bien entouré dans le nommant des
choses et à ce moment-là ans on compte
que yann il ya un monde
un monde que l'orge qui kills et qui
nous est proposé qui nous est offert
voilà et c'est ce que j'ai voulu appeler
quoi que la nature nous offre des choses
et que on est parfois trop bête pour en
tout cas en ce qu'elle vient mettre de
ne pas accepter ces cadeaux quelques
photographes de la ruralité
cette fois ci avec au fond si la
ruralité et l'écologie c'est la ruralité
et l'écologie c'est la preuve que je
suis un peu comme tout le monde nous
avons une somme fait de plusieurs
facettes
il ya il y a chiche du groupe
c'est vrai qu'on m'a connu comme étant
l'auteur de l'image de la campagne la
martinique damon en noir et blanc etc
mais ça c'est moi mais ça aussi c'est
moins pratique cela tout en faisant les
photos de la campagne qui nous photo
faisant des photos des chambres de la
campagne ben j'ai toujours eu une
attirance pour des photos comme ça de la
nature de l'eau qui coule de nombres qui
me parlent ou du sable
j'ai toujours eu ces photos des sauces
ou des photos que je faisais tout à fait
innocemment et et j'aimais bien ça
l'idée que que les photos je les faisais
juste parce que je trouvais ça beau j'ai
eu l'occasion ne s'est plus d'une fois
auprès des gens pour qu'ils prennent
conscience de la nature et c'est ainsi
que dernièrement il ya eu
un travail de fait sur le littoral
martiniquais avec l'agencé comme pas
géométriques et c'est d'ici qu'il ya eu
un travail de fait avec les gens à cette
marie autour des pêcheurs et de ce que
propose cette manne
et voilà c'est ma manière à moi et je
veux que je suis un militant de la photo
je suis un militant images
j'ai même crié avec jandy une
association à millau qui a pour objet de
promouvoir l'image photographique
ben voila je fais je fais un peu comme
le colibri je fais ma petit chapeau de
ma petite goutte d'eau
en espérant que ça contribuables